and also terminology let's take Stepford
Wives consciousness-raising group well
no one says that anymore
right and and if you were to I think
only people born after a certain or you
know they would turn their heads and say
wow I haven't heard that in a while
so there's different terminology that
today if someone I I hear a lot of
people that are twenty five to nineteen
whatever epoch they're always saying
epoch which I was like wait a minute
what does that what does that really
mean because it's used all the time for
everything so if someone doesn't have
let's say kids or isn't in malls or in a
class rules how do they pick up on
today's terminology today no I think I
think the greatest I mean again I just
talked about YouTube being the thing
where people now know everything but
YouTube is also the way that we can
learn things so you can actually watch
youtube videos of people there's you
know there's a trailer before the movies
that's all about YouTube sensations Jack
and Jack and I'm going I don't know who
the hell these two guys are but they're
famous and they showed Jack and Jack
welcome to the street and just people
mob in them and like okay I gotta find
out who the hell jack and jack are
because Jack and Jack are famous people
that I've never heard of before they're
on YouTube so but YouTube is one of
those things you can go there you can
watch endless 15 year-olds talk and
figure out you know their their
terminology now their slang now the
other thing this which gets into
research the other thing with research
research and YouTube is we now have the
ability to see across the world things
that we could never see before because
now we can watch them on YouTube and I
did a script that took place I did a
we're with Finland so I did this script
which was a US Finland co-production
thing hasn't gotten made probably never
will get made but nonetheless I got paid
and I've never been to Finland so I
thought how can I write about how can I
write a movie that takes place in
Finland if I've never been there and I
thought tourists have tourists have
posted their their their home videos on
YouTube so I went to YouTube and watched
a whole bunch of people tourists home
videos and so you get to see all the
buildings you get to see little
landmarks that you would only know it
you if you've been there right as these
people were so I wrote a script based on
home videos on YouTube which sounds
really creepy doesn't it you know I'm
watching other people's home videos but
but you know I got to see buildings I
got to see tours of places all these
things and one of the things that the
Finland producer loved about it was he
said so you have this great you know
fast-food kind of a place that is not a
chain it's a place that people just go
and get fish because it's Finland fried
fish and he goes you know nobody knows
about that except people that live in
Helsinki I'm like awesome you know and
he asked me when I was in Helsinki I'm
like never been there somebody else had
it in their tourist movie you know and
and there was like people waiting in
line to buy fish fried fish and so all
of that stuff YouTube now becomes the
way for us to learn about the current
generation it becomes waste for us to
learn about things that happen in other
sides of the world we want if we're
doing a foreign identity type story and
we're gonna go spies in a different
country we've never been to that country
it used to be you would go to the
library and look at you know picture
books and now we don't only get picture
books we get movies we get all kinds of
stuff I I did a script that took place
in Detroit and wanted to have a scene on
8 mile cuz I know about it because of a
movie and thought I'm gonna look at 8
mile and see what what's on that road
and so somebody literally posted to
YouTube them shooting one side of the
street and the other side of the street
and I went there's a motel I can use
there's a fast-food place I can use
that's that's not your main your chain
fast food but as the you know Detroit
only kind of a fast food all this stuff
they gave it the real flavor of Detroit
without me ever going anywhere I just
went on YouTube
you